yes
here we go again
live and full effect
welcome back
let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to
another live episode of your favorite
podcast
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we back again we're
from with griffin um
what's going on this episode let's see i
went to dallas i did some shows at the
improv
i had a sunday show so i couldn't do my
podcast
i got in an early flight so i was up
super late i was tired i just woke up
and i got to do the podcast i got to
keep it going uh i talk about my
favorite show
right now sex education on netflix
big brother 23 champ was crowned and my
new cartoon 10 year old tom is out
though we gonna get into all that once
again
[Music]
[Music]
feel like the pipes are back in full
effect
all right what's up everybody thanks for
being here thanks for everybody that's
uh
that's live right now watching live and
if you people are listening you know
sometimes you got to catch it live i
don't know when i don't really have a
set schedule but you know when i do it
live i do do it on mondays like right
now it's monday at 3 52 p.m pacific time
so
we're a little late but we're doing it
uh but before we get started let's get
into a little business
liquid iv i want to thank liquid iv for
sponsoring this episode grab your
favorite liquid iv flavors nationwide in
walmart or you get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code griffin at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today using promo code griffin at liquid
iv.com
all right oh wait i don't want that
noise i hear some noise
okay there we go
that little little thing what makes
noise anyways
all right guys so you know i'm doing a
new background every week well every
time i do it live i have a new
background so i asked the fans out there
you guys if you want to change the
background of riffing with griffin uh so
we're now we're someplace else today we
are at willie peacock's house
i think that's his name will peacock i
think is on instagram it's not like a
fake name but i think that that's his
name so will thanks for sending out the
uh
the background it's a beautiful house
he's got right there so that's gonna be
today's background uh for riffing with
griffin we're out at will we're out at
will's place everybody so if you want to
send a background picture of anything
don't have yourself in it because
that'll just be distracting but if you
have like a room or you have something
like a backyard that you like or you
have some funny place you want me to be
you know send it in you can send it to
me on instagram or you can even email me
at eric ericgriffin.com and i will
put the background of my podcast when
you're watching for the video on youtube
you'll be able to see what it is so
that's shout out to will peacock uh
thank you and um you know i'm looking at
the chat live right now we're gonna
we're doing what we're doing guys this
is one of these last minute situations i
am prepared because i have stuff that i
wanted to talk about but you know when
you're a one-man show
it's difficult i mean i can't get wigs
in here because it's like it's difficult
because i was traveling and i just got
back from dallas and remember always
catch me live every day most days
on eric griffin gay men
on twitch era griffin gaming on twitch
so make sure you guys check me out there
um
let's see
let's look at the chat
all right chat how you guys doing all
right nobody cares
i see you guys but you actually the chat
is too far over except to look to my
right like this and thanks for the super
chats guys appreciate your super chats
all right there there's the all right
there we go that's better i can see the
chat better like this
all right you know daddy's going blind
i don't know it is what it is
you know i like doing podcasts you know
you guys like listening to podcasts you
know i'm do uh you know kids i've been
doing a lot of king in the sting and i
appreciate the king and the sting fans
that come out to the shows and they love
they come up to me at the shows they
love telling me
you know it's like hey man i heard you
on king of the sting you know so i'm
like all right that's pretty that that's
kind of cool you know what i mean
it is what it is
you know good fan good fan base
so i appreciate the opportunities i got
on there and i appreciate you guys being
here
when i'm live with you guys
um got my hero mode hat on that was a
movie i was in with bobby lee actually
hero mode so make sure you check that
out
all right let's see i also want to do
like you know i didn't i didn't have
this ready you know but i am going to
start doing this a list of my list of
the week of
bitching with griffin
like the things that what do i want to
[ __ ] about this week it's just like
things that come up when you go even
though they're little innocuous things
it don't matter it's part of my brand
you're bitching with griffin you know
it's like when you check like you know
you check into the hotel what what are
they typing on the computer that's
taking so long
like i have a reservation you know i'm
coming
what are you doing back there that you
don't have this thing ready already like
why are you like typing up a dossier
uh on the computer
like you making a facebook profile for
me every time i check into a a hotel
it's like i have a reservation put all
that stuff in i have an account with the
hotel you know what i mean like if it's
marriott you already got my information
what you what you writing
what you what you what you uh right
typing on the computer you know what i
mean
it don't make no sense man someone have
a list like that my top five of the week
i'm gonna start doing that top five
quick hitters of the week of uh things
and if you have your own too if you
think like hey man what do you think
about this this happens to me and if i
if i want to if i co-sign it boom
it'll uh make it onto the podcast so you
know it is what it is
i went to um oh by the way you know so
like rachel and i are trying to plan
this wedding
you know we're trying to plan this
wedding and i've got some people that
have hit me up like hey man i'll dj for
you know dj your wedding or somebody
else was like we'll take pictures for
you or so you know we are looking for
stuff like that man you know we're
looking for like you know if you want to
be a part of the the rachel and eric
wedding experience and you have
something to offer
you know what i mean we put it out there
it's like a it's like a gofundme but
but not really
you know man weddings are expensive
you know so i don't know maybe there's
some wedding venue out there that they
want some pub and they'd be like oh
we'll do the rachel and eric wedding and
come to our villa whatever it is like
that that's what we're kind of looking
for but you know it is what it is
so you know rachel keeps asking me to
talk about it you know because maybe she
wants some fancy wedding dress or some
jewelry or maybe she wants some like
hair salon that's going to be like oh
we'll we'll left we'll do you up that
day and do your makeup and stuff like
that so who knows whatever you know
maybe you got a catering company and
you're looking for some advertisement i
don't know
it is what it is
um all right somebody in the chat keeps
talking about the cowboys and
we don't care about the cowboys the way
you care about the cowboys so if you
keep it up you will get a time out
so that's how that works son
that's how that works
actually that's how it works we i
haven't given somebody a timeout in a
while in a few days
so
there he's timed out nobody cares
um all right um so let's see so i went
to dallas i was in dallas this weekend
and you know it's just
you know it's weird like you guys if
you're not a person that travels and
you're like in your state wherever you
are you know you've been dealing with
whatever the covert restrictions are in
your place and so you have your own
perspective on like if you're in
california man like we're here in
california sometimes i felt
institutionalized in comparison to other
places you know but we don't know how it
is in other places until you go so i
remember the first time i went out of
town i went to arizona and it was the
first time i've been inside a restaurant
in a year and they just they doing their
thing you know and so they had their
restrictions and you know you go to
boston i was just in boston and they
have their
they have their thing then i was in new
york and new york is one of these like
vaccinated to get in places places so
like you have to deal with that and then
you know you i was in denver and it was
the same thing it was like denver was
more like some places you go there like
you know they'll have a sign that says
like if you you know
use them we suggest you use a mask but
if you're vaccinated you don't have to
it's like it's like the signs read like
that uh and then there's other places
where it's like if you're indoors you
have to wear a mask you know so you know
it's it's just a lot when you're like
traveling as much as i do it's like okay
so what weird thing is it going to be at
this place i mean that's the thing
there's no consistency so it's like okay
so now i'm in a city that like all right
so they they care about it at this level
they think it's okay to be like this uh
and then you're like okay so now you
know you get
at least when you're on the plane it's
all the same it's like you know when
you're at the airport as soon as you get
to the airport that's the transition the
airport is the transition place where
it's like everybody wears a mask no
matter what and then when you get off
the plane and you walk outside that
airport of wherever you are then this
the new thing you know and i always know
depending on who picks me up like if
they have like a car service pick me up
and like the guy comes to get my bag you
know then like he don't got a mask on
then i'm like okay i know what kind of
place we're at right now this is a place
where they're just like okay i wear a
mask when i need to and i don't when i
don't you know and then there's other
places you get there and the guy's got a
mask and a face shield and you're just
like all right so now i got to be in the
back of this car you know you know
he's worried about this and it's you
know it's case by case but it's just
weird man if you're not traveling so you
don't know so you're just like you're
you have your own
understanding or anger or frustration or
you're just whatever you feel about it
in your city you're dealing with that
you know it's like even though it
changes in your city but imagine like
you travel someplace else and you go
well i was just at a place where you had
to do this
and this place is like well we do it
this way and it's like how can so many
different places
treat the same exact thing differently
you know like that is
that's the freaking
that's that's the thing man you know
what i mean so i i just i just don't
know
uh it's hard to look at the chat guys so
sorry you know i mean if you got some
nonsense you're saying in the chat i
can't necessarily
i'm you know i'm a one-man show right
now so i can't you know i can't look at
the chat and
you know do do i'm doing a live podcast
okay guys
uh
you know so it's like it's a weird thing
you know what i mean you go to different
places so you just you know you get used
to it it's just like i say it's just
like it's interesting is what i'm saying
you know it's interesting to like you
know
go to a place and you like it's like you
know with the like with the whatever the
restaurant thing is i thought denver was
more lacks than some places i've been to
you know like in texas
and you know i i really just depends on
like how they're enforcing it so like
there are places that like i think in
california they're pretty strict about
like you walk into a restaurant they
want you to have your mask on then
they'll seat you at a table and then you
can take your mask off some of these
places like you walk in
and you could tell like it's like okay
some people have it on some people don't
some people are waiting some people
don't you know they're waiting with it
with it without it and so you know you
go and you know you know you're just
like you know you're just kind of like
all right where where are we at with
this so it's like you know when you're
going some places like when you're
traveling it's best to like you know you
have to just have a mask with you and
then you could determine like okay do i
need this or not because sometimes i
forget because i don't go out a lot i
just stay like if i'm staying even when
i go on the road i'm not going a lot of
places i just i'm at the hotel i go to
the club because i don't want to deal
with all that i just don't want to deal
with it a mask make me uncomfortable so
well i do my part by staying away from
people
so you know it just depends uh you know
i and then you have this thing too where
like you know some of the clubs are
going well they're going to all
vaccinated shows
and i don't know if they're doing that
for safety health and safety or if
they're doing it for liability or
probably a combination of both
you know it's probably a combination of
both really i would lean more towards
liability than any anyplace else even
though it's just odd to me that like you
know you're a person you want to go out
you want to drink eat laugh amongst
people but you want to blame the the
place that you're going to
because there's a global pandemic and
you want to blame the place you're going
to i've talked about that before i think
that's ridiculous
i wish it felt like it was all about
health and safety but i could just you
get the sense that it's not all about
health and safety you get a sense that
it's about
hey we're trying not to get sued you
know
which i just feel like it should be like
i don't know if you've ever been to like
a taping of something or like let's say
you go someplace and it's a big crowd
and they're trying to record well a lot
of times they'll put a sign up that says
if you enter this building you're
agreeing that you're you can it's okay
to be recorded you know they have that
there and that's their catch-all for
like you know
in case somebody's like hey i saw myself
you have to pay me you know i think it
should be like that
for in a public venues where there's a
lot of people congregating
i think it should be like you have an
agreement
i'm saying i want to go watch this
basketball game i want to watch this
comedy show i want to watch this concert
i'm saying i'm willing to take the risk
of getting covet by going there i
absolve you location of any uh liability
i mean that's what i think
that's what i think it should be
you know what i mean
it's so
i don't know that's just my feeling on
it
but everybody has their own thing you
know a lot of people don't want to take
personal responsibility for their own
stuff and they they need to blame other
people for things that happen to them
and if you're one of those people i get
it do you you know what i mean
but
that's just um
you know that that's that is what it is
so yes but uh i'll say dallas was great
so everybody that came out to dallas i
appreciate it saturday night shows were
really great
uh that club is set we were set up weird
you know it's like this long area than a
short area but you know it is what it is
uh great great crowds that came out to
dallas
let's see where i'm gonna be
coming up here
actually i actually oh man just this
calendar actually isn't complete
because i have some new
i have some new dates coming up
you know
yeah so i did last did it so i have the
arlington draft house coming up the
house of comedy in vancouver side
splitters and the house of comedy in
edmonton but actually i just added like
three more dates in between this
so i'm gonna be at la jolla comedy store
and i'm gonna be at miami improv and i'm
gonna do flappers in burbank so look out
for those things too guys look out for
that
um
you know
so yeah so that that's uh that and i'm
still i'm still working on this
ridiculous website
all right so let's talk about some stuff
that i wanted to talk about
some stuff that's going on in my life
all right the first one is so the new
cartoon
i was i was working on a cartoon during
the pandemic and it's called
ten-year-old tom i don't know why that
sex education thing keeps coming out but
anyway i'm gonna talk about that too but
ten-year-old tom guys ten-year-old tom
is on
hbo max
hbo max and
it's actually a it's actually a really
funny show
uh it's created by steve
i don't i would never say his name right
dildarian i don't know if i'm saying
that right but
anyways
you know it's about a 10 year old you
know but it's really adult humor because
it's on hbo max and so hbo it's not on
hbo like it comes out every week it's
actually on hbo max the streaming
service so all 10 episodes are already
out and i play the coach and it's like
this i didn't realize how extensive the
cast is man if you look at this cast man
it's so steve the creator who's created
a bunch of other things too byron bowers
comic buddy of mine look at that todd
glass
edie patterson myself
john malkovich is in it which i didn't
know jennifer coolidge like look at all
these people man
a lot of great actors voice actors and
even santino's in it santino he uh
he plays like he plays a couple of
characters i think but he was this one
character that was like my character was
working at a mexican restaurant and he
plays like the manager so we have this
great scene together
um you know so that's like look at all
these people in this so it's actually
it's pretty funny like i like adult
cartoons you know i don't know about you
guys
or like cartoons that have like sort of
like mature humor not like adult humor
where it has to be like cursing and it
has to be dirty or something like that
but i like the humor that's like
you know it's adult references you know
it's like if you think back to like what
is it um like
man um like shrek
like what makes a show like shrek a
movie like shrek good it's like because
you know the kids see all the light the
cartoon characters and all the stuff and
the fun stuff that's happening but
they're making jokes that you know you
go oh that's for the adults that are
taking their kids to the this movie and
you could just enjoy it as an adult as a
kid that's a that's a hard balance to
feel but ten-year-old tom is
this is really for adults like you know
kids can't watch this because there's
cursing and stuff like that uh the
animation the animation is is weird i
didn't i didn't know the animation was
gonna be like that but it's actually a
specific style
uh you know if you're into that sort of
like if you're into art that way you
might you might be like oh i really
enjoy whatever that is but it does have
like a
a specific style like all the noses are
drawn
with the same thing well you know this
is from this world
um it's great man uh
you know i i when i
when i'm in something the first thing i
do is i go to it and i fast forward to
my stuff because i want to see like how
did i how did this come out and then i
watched the full episode just to get
like a taste of it and the pilot of this
episode is actually episode one is
really funny so if you have
excuse me if you have hbo max
go check that out and i actually played
two characters in the first episode
which i didn't get it didn't i didn't
really get credit for it
you don't see it in the credits like who
to care i don't know i have to
play again but i was like a pastor and
i'm the coach
um so it's uh
it's uh it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool
it's pretty cool to be a part of it
because then now i'm i was looking at
some of the reviews and it's like people
really like this cartoon it's like
getting a lot of really great reviews
so i really i really like that like on
imdb it's got an 8 out of ten
uh i said yeah i saw a lot of really
good reviews actually let's look that up
right now reviews of
10 year old tom you know yeah since
we're on the fly
we could just look right here yeah the
let's see
um the hollywood reporter looks like it
had a good review
yeah
yeah so it's like you know you're gonna
you have to just go down to the bottom
you know and it says
yeah it says ten-year-old tom is well
worth checking out
so after like eight paragraphs of like
talking about all this stuff
ten-year-old tom is well worth checking
out
you know it's so that's that's pretty
cool that when you're a part of
something that people
when you're a part of something that
people really like i wish i i can't show
a clip because like youtube will like
ding it you know
you i don't know why they do that but
youtube will ding it also oh by the way
there's something else i was in that i
did and i i did like a it's a it was for
ibm but it's like a it's like an espn
fantasy football is really the product i
think
i did a commercial and i'm in this
commercial and they they show me twice
in the commercial like cd lamb gets hurt
and i'm like at the doctor's office and
i see that you know i hold my phone up
like does this look bad you know what i
mean so that commercial is uh that
commercial is out so
make sure you check that out too but you
know i'm trying to think of like some of
the cartoons that i really like like
what are my top
adult-ish type cartoons i never was a
simpsons guy
i don't know what you guys thinking um
uh what do you call it
in the chat here you know thank you
robert paul for the the the
super chat
i i don't know
i never was a simpsons guy because i
always felt like you had to like smoke
weed to like the simpsons or just
everyone i knew
everyone i knew that smoked weed loved
the simpsons so i just never really got
into it but i am a huge family guy dude
i love family guy and i love american
dad
i just those two cartoons are just two
of my favorite sort of adult cartoons
you know like you wouldn't necessarily
let
you know you wouldn't let um
your kids watch those cartoons
you know
and if you want to i see people in the
chat asking about a squid games review
that means you don't really listen to my
podcast because i reviewed that last
week so that's last week's episode i
reviewed squid games so if you want to
take a look at that
go check that out
you know if you want to see
what i had to say about damn
all right so let's go on to something
else here all right i got to go to this
i'm doing this by myself
uh all right
all right so
i am let's talk about
let's talk about
um
big
brother
okay
let's see
yes
so you know as you know i'm a huge big
brother fan
and these are the final three from big
brother that's xavier
this chick right here ozza and derek f
derek frazier who's actually the son of
great late
boxer uh jo
was it clyde joe frazier
so
you know as i've talked about before
you know they had this alliance that
they had they had an alliance that was
all
that was all black okay it was all black
alliance
they came into the house they saw each
other
and then this guy derek was like you
know why don't we have a secret alliance
from day one they had a secret alliance
of six
and they made it all the way to the end
and this they crowned the first black
african-american
big brother winner in the 20-something
plus years of this show
you know so
i don't care about that stuff anymore
my like i said last week
my feeling on this is
they made it if it was all white and six
people started an alliance no one would
care about race it would just be like
these six people
connived lied schemed and got everybody
else out
these people did the same thing they
formed an alliance they just happen to
be all black it is what it is you know
they stuck together they made it bigger
than themselves and it is what it is
so who cares
but the only thing i say now is that
xavier one this guy on the left on the
screen xavier
you know so it's two ball hair black
guys and ozza the one woman you know but
like this guy xavier there was no way he
wasn't gonna win the only way he wasn't
gonna win is if one of them won the hoh
and kicked him out
but if he was sitting in the final chair
there's no way you could have voted
anyone else anyone else the winner of
the final six except for that guy kai
and that's why the xavier guy
connived and got him kicked out for you
people that don't watch big brother it's
like you know this competition show and
they have to like do these like athletic
competitions they have to do these like
brain competitions
against each other and to like you know
gain power in the house and then they
have the ability to nominate people to
get kicked out and it happens all season
so and then it gets harder when it
breaks down to the fine to final people
so it was these three left and it was
just to me no possible way i mean the
guy won so many competitions he won the
brain ones he won the athletic ones you
know he was sitting next to this other
guy derek in the final they were the
final two and this guy derek didn't win
one competition all year and why didn't
he win any of them he didn't win any of
the athletic ones because he's a fat guy
and you know i felt for him i was like
damn i would love to be on big brother
but i know i can't do these endurance
competitions and all this stuff i would
have felt i would have been the first
one out of that that stuff too
so i just but that guy made it to the
final two but here's the problem with it
though so you so if you're someone out
there being like well the you know look
the fat guy made it so here's the thing
though
you have zero respect for how he made it
because
you see this other guy
all the things that he won so the only
reason why you would let you would pick
the other guy because what happens to is
like the last nine people to get kicked
out of big brother they're the jury that
decides who wins the game
so they're one they're the ones that are
in there you know they got lied to they
got kicked out they got like they built
alliances they had friendships and
they're the ones that have to decide all
right we think you should win
like we think you should you know win
because of this and sometimes it's been
bitterness like i've seen after the
seasons there was a season where this
guy paul
he was on the show two years in a row
and he lost he came second two years in
a row
but the second time
i felt like he
played the big brother game the best got
to the end but the thing he messed up
was jury management the people that he
sent out they hated him so
when they when it was the final vote
to vote they voted against him because
they hated him because they were bitter
[ __ ] really you know that i i thought
this is how the game is going to be
played but you know what that's all part
of it like big brother's big brother
like one thing i didn't like about this
like fi the final part of this season is
like so this other guy kai
you know he's all like
he thinks that well you know we should
play with honor and you know if there's
more things more important than money
and you know because because he got
kicked out he he got blindsided i
thought it was so stupid because it's
like yo dude this is the game this is
what you sign up for you don't sign up
for a game and change the rules to suit
what you think it's going to be like you
know if you're saying that there's
nothing there's things that are more
important than money then you know what
don't be on the show cause this show is
about money this show is about being the
last person standing and you win 750 000
you know what you played with honor you
left with zero
no one is sitting out here going oh man
you know that dude that didn't do the
line and scheming that everybody's done
for 23 years to make it to the end ah
that guy he's the real winner nobody's
saying that dude no one is saying that
it was actually a stupid thought process
and i can't stand it all those people
that think like that when they go into
big brother but at the end they're like
you know i just wanted to play the game
the right way or i just wanted to like
you know i didn't want to have people
hate me whatever the nonsense you're
thinking
the true big brother fans know that's
how you play the game it's
manipulation lies deceit to make it to
the end and if you're not on board with
that what the hell you doing in the big
brother house
somebody tell me you know like what are
you doing here so i'm sorry that that
guy to me came off as just ignorant
misguided you know it just was stupid
and misguided so i don't know man
i'm already getting pictures somebody
already sent me a picture
of their living room
all right nice one so that i might use
that one next week so if you want to
send a picture you can email me at eric
eric griffin.com you have a picture you
want me to send of your office uh just
anywhere anything funny too if you just
have something like just just super
hilarious that you want to be the
background of my podcast go ahead
but anyways yeah man this big brother
was it was interesting season but it was
just so anti-climactic
and i often wonder like what were the
ratings i mean you know we we often make
everything about race so i wonder if
there were people who were like i don't
want to watch this or how do people
really feel about it like we're the true
big brother fans like what do you think
about this could you could you divorce
yourself of like having to think about
politics and race and everything because
like that's all there is you know i mean
i'm i'm i'm um i'm a culprit of that
sometimes too but you know i'm analyzing
things and i'm talking about it like
this but you know the the the macro view
of it is it's still like oh well
unfortunately everything boils down to
politics race religion and things like
that and it just sucks i can't stand
when that gets in the way of like hey we
just want to say how do we feel about
this season what do we think about these
people that like they they formulated
this great plan they manipulated
everybody and made it to the end like
can we just celebrate that or do we have
to always think about it in this like
sort of like oh man this is there's a
social thing about it i mean
i just hope we can just get past all
that stuff one day because i feel like
we're in a state right now that we can't
even like you know
like you're not allowed to dislike
something
just for the sake of like
hey i don't like this hey i think this
is bad you know you know what i mean
like i think this is bad i didn't like
it
so
uh you know it's like there's a show on
hbo called black lady sketch show that's
the name of the show black lady sketch
show
i mean
do you think hbo
could ever cancel a show called
black lady sketch show
you think they could cancel that show
like
what a brilliant name for a show
it's so brit like it's like
that is how you do it come up with a
name for a show that if they cancel the
show
people will be like oh
you're only doing this because they're
ladies because they're black because
they're you know it's like it's like i
just think if that was the thought
process
in naming that show
uh like
kudos to you kudos to you but
yeah i'm a huge big brother fan i don't
like a lot of reality shows i'm not like
big on like there's very few that i
really watch
like these kind of like these type of
reality competition shows you know i
don't like i've never watched survivor
you know well i guess let me think about
it like i love 90 day fiance and those
type of shows but that's not necessarily
a competition show but i haven't watched
him in a while and then i like naked and
afraid sometimes or like any of those
kind of survivor ones survival like you
know they're but my only problem with it
is
when they're doing this survival thing i
can't get past the fact that
there's a camera crew there
you know like i like the one where the
dude is clearly filming himself with a
gopro
and you know like i like that like they
tell like you know it's like you you get
a sense that he's out there by himself
with a gopro
and if he makes it back with the gopro
you know boom then here's the show but
if he doesn't make it back or like what
are they gonna do right
so i don't know
i forgot i don't know what that one's
called anybody know what that one's
called
it's like survivor something i don't
know but but i don't like a lot of
reality shows uh
but but big brother's my one that's my
guilty pleasure i love uh big
big
brother
big brother
all right
before we go on we got to pay some bills
everybody uh we gotta we gotta pay these
bills can you pay my bills pay my tail
upon bills
so let's get back to it uh liquid iv
everybody
liquid iv
um you know you need those um
i don't know what to say about liquid iv
other than i guess it's pretty good i
they sent me some and i used it and i
really liked it
uh you know it's like it's got a good
taste to it you know it's like one stick
of liquid iv is 16 and 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than just water alone you
get the electrolytes they got great
flavors
you know and it's just like you know
that's what you need i mean
i'm at an age where i got to drink a lot
of water because i got a lot of things i
need to hydrate or they're going are
they going to get dusted up
you know
so it's like it's like good for like if
you're gonna start working out you're
going on a walk that's the thing you you
know you take the first thing in the
morning or you take it when you're about
to do a run because daily hydration and
maintenance it's super important if
you're a drinker liquid iv is great to
help you get over a hangover that's what
i i don't drink but that's what i hear
about liquid iv they got great flavors
they got lemon lime strawberry
watermelon passion fruit guava pina
colada they got immune boost tangerine
i mean they got this great the optimal
ratio of glucose sodium and potassium
delivers water nutrients into the
bloodstream i mean liquid iv does the
job you know it's kind of you know it's
it's it's like you know it's it's a good
cost as opposed to like buying those
like electrolyte drinks we won't name
them you know this is a better better
version of that because you're
controlling it yourself you know grab
your favorite liquid eye
iv flavors nationwide at walmart or you
can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code griffin at
checkout guys that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today using promo code griffin at liquid
iv.com
check that out guys
also sponsor the show once again is
better help guys
better help you know i love better help
i think therapy is super important right
now a lot of things in our life
interfere with our happiness
you know you and it's good to talk to a
professional therapist who will help you
organize your thoughts help you pinpoint
the causes of why you're feeling the way
you're feeling therapy sometimes has a
stigma and i'm telling you we need to
break that you know it's like you're not
crazy you're not whatever you think you
are just because you're talking to
someone like when you talk to a
professional therapist and that's how
you get here you know they're gonna help
you understand why you're feeling the
way you're feeling and that's the thing
that we don't understand we think that
we do and then you talk with this
therapist who might be like well you
know
this this is like because they've seen
these patterns before and they'll
pinpoint it and you'll be like oh i
didn't even think of it like that it's
not gonna solve your problem it's just
gonna help you get through them man they
help with depression stress anxiety like
relationship stuff you have anger issues
you got family conflicts you got
self-esteem issues
lgbt matters sleeping trauma whatever
you think this it's convenient it's
confidential and it's for you i'm i
cannot stress enough therapy has helped
me and i'm telling you it will help you
in fact so many people have been using
better help recently that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states this isn't self-help it's
professional counseling now i want you
to start living a happier life today as
a listener you'll get 10 percent off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
at betterhelp.com
griffin join over one million people who
take charge of their mental health
that's better help
h-e-l-p dot com slash griffin for 10
off your first month
start living happier life guys today
would better help
all right we paid the bills
we paid the bills y'all you know i got
to work on my green screen like i'm the
light or something that's like i i mess
with it maybe it's it's because of that
blue in the chair i don't know man
it's just like it's so frustrating but
anyways
um all right what else do we want to
talk about oh yep i see it we wanted to
talk about this this
show
all right so i'm gonna finish off with
this show
it's called sex education
sex education on
netflix
i don't know if anybody's seen uh
this show
but let me look up the imdb
yeah
sex education on netflix i just started
watching this and they got three seasons
so i'm only on season one right now
i'm just on season one
but it is actually a really great show
um really great show
uh i don't know i see people in the chat
they're asking like are you in your
living room
uh so everybody that's joining the chat
late or joining the podcast late and
people listening right now too and if
you want to check out if you want to
watch on youtube please do it you know
eric griffin podcast i couldn't get rid
of mcgriff for some reason it's so weird
i'm still working on it but anyways
um
if you want to send me a picture
because rick glassman got on me he was
like yo man you have that black
background i want to be a part of what
you're doing so can you like you know
put some you know
show me your environment so i thought oh
you know what a better idea is like you
guys show me your environment where do
you want me to be where do you want me
to be doing the podcast so if you send
me a picture of your living room your
kitchen your bedroom your bath i don't
care what if it's a funny picture if
it's a good looking picture it's going
to be the background of an episode and
this one the one i've been using today
is from will peacock he sent it to me
on instagram so thanks will but anyway
let's talk about sex education uh such
education really great show let's look
at the cast uh
the cast is really oh wow look at that
kid he looks so different right there in
that picture look at this look at this
picture
yeah that the main guy who plays otis
asa
butterfield he was actually in ender's
games he's actually in a lot of movies
that i don't know why the movies don't
do well
you know you know what i mean like he's
actually been in a bun let's look at his
imdb
oh yeah he looks so different right
there but he's been in a lot of movies
man he was in hugo he was in ender games
he was in you know he this is i think
his biggest hit is sex education
uh let's see
yeah he's been in a lot of stuff man
he was in um
the journey's end
he's in a lot of like sci-fi stuff
but he's a really tremendous actor i
really appreciate
i appreciate his acting
and he's really good in this
so
sex education
is about this
young
sort of nerdy guy
you know he's like a nerdy guy and he he
like he lives um you know he lives with
his mom
who's a and his mom's a sex therapist
you know
there you wait let me move out of the
way so you can see him there he is right
there nope right there
so he plays otis
and he you know is this kind of like
really weird kind of you know socially
awkward guy
who is living with his mom who's
divorced and and she was a therapist and
her ex-husband was a therapist and i
think they're like sex therapists and
you know this you see how this has
affected his life and you know whatever
you know i'm going to spoil it
and he goes to school with this kid this
this kid right here who plays uh this
kid named he plays a guy named eric but
his name is i don't know i don't know
how to say his name nukati
gatwa
and that dude is hilarious he's playing
his gay best friend
but the dude is a really great actor and
he's so funny
and then that girl is like the uh his
like love interest in the show
her name is emma oh she looks so
different her name is emma mckay she
plays maeve in the show it's i think the
whole cast is british and i think it's
filmed in
europe you know
it seems to be
uh you know and so anyway you know he
goes to school he goes to school and
he's not part he's not a popular kid him
and his buddy are just not the popular
kids you know what i mean as you can
imagine but
he like has picked up some like real
good common sense
you know like he's got like his own
segment it would be like real world
advice from a nerdy teenager like that's
what his podcast would be what he would
do and it's actually really good so you
know he ends up
he ends up giving like
sex advice to his peers and this girl
that plays maeve she sets up what she
calls the clinic where these these high
school kids pay
him to give them advice but it's also
about the little the stories that are
going on how their lives unfold and the
unrequited love and all this kind of
stuff but you know if you're into like
british humor
uh it's very biting and it's uh but i
find it to be funny and and um very
smart edgy humor it's a very smart edgy
show it's you know it's very it's very
sexual but not in a gratuitous way it's
very much like a really good
it's a really good example of how you
know what you're feeling when you're a
teenager when your body is changing when
you don't know anything about sex you
don't know anything about the opposite
sex and you're just kind of like
what is this about i don't know
you know what this show is you know i
don't know who i am and like like how
what kind of sexy person am i or
can i do sex well or whatever it is like
that this show really explores those
young teen axed feelings so i do highly
recommend you watching sex education i'm
still on the first season right now
there's three seasons on netflix so i'll
continue to talk about it as it goes on
um you know like last week i talked
about that show counterpoint and it
you know it was great
yeah yeah you know what i mean like it
um
it ended great so i don't i'm not even
sure if they're gonna do
another season of counterpoint with jake
jake jk simmons
said his name yeah i don't know if they
can do another season or not but they
did tie it up really nicely so i don't
know if anybody's checking out
counterpoint but make sure you check
that out and again last week i did
review squid games so check out episode
153 if you want to see squid games and i
did a total spoiler recap of the movie
voyeur last week i'm going to do that
again i'm going to pick another i kind
of liked doing that i just want to pick
a really terrible movie that i swatch
and i just want to recap it on the
podcast it's just of all the little
crazy moments because it was like i
actually gonna pick a bruce willis movie
because man i don't know if y'all know
but bruce willis is in a lot of terrible
movies man like the movies you wouldn't
even think like i'm on an airplane and i
see some space movie and i'm like what
is this and it's like oh bruce willis
you go okay what's this about and man
you just go how did he make this how did
he make this just terrible so i might
find another good movie to recap so did
anybody in the chat watch voyeur after
after my uh
after my thing
you know anybody uh
watch voyeur uh on on amazon you got to
watch it man even though i spoiled the
whole movie you have to watch it for
yourself to see how
see how crazy it was
you know so anyways just to recap
you know big brother 23 xavier won
ugh i mean it just was so anti-climactic
because he was the only one that could
win you know it's just like he deserved
to win and he won you kind of you kind
of want to see uh some some changes to
it you know what i mean
and then um make sure you check out 10
year old tom on
hbo mac that's the cartoon i'm in right
now it's getting rave reviews people are
really loving the show i don't know if
y'all if y'all have seen it
you know what i mean if if you've seen
it uh let you know let me know what you
think about it it's actually really
really interesting show
you know um
it's really funny 10 years home it's
just you know it's really adult humor so
it's really for that and then also sex
education so make sure you check out sex
education on netflix and let me know
what you think about that too i think
like i say i think it's a really
interesting show a good coming of age
story i don't know why we love those
kinds of stories especially when it's
like teens you know because you kind of
look back and you feel nostalgic about
like oh man i remember when i felt that
way and how did i get past this and
there's a lot of great relationships on
uh the sex education show uh between you
know father and son relationship there's
a lot of good father and son
relationships on uh sex education
actually yeah you know what that's
actually a really cool theme that's
going on in the show now that i think
about it as i'm talking about it right
now there's a lot of like
all different types of father-son
relationships and how your father's
actions affect who you are uh so that's
yeah oh wow that's going to make me look
at it in a whole different way so uh
make sure you uh you make sure you check
that out let me know what you feel about
it all right
um
yeah so i don't know and again once
again i'm gonna be on uh eric griffin
gaming i'm about to get on air griffin
gaming after i put all this stuff
together the audio version of the
podcast you know i'm i'm putting that up
as we speak
you know so probably if you're listening
to it that's what i was doing so like i
have to tape i have to record this live
and then when i end it i gotta download
the uh i gotta download the the file to
get the audio which i should have just
recorded the audio myself anyway right
and then i would already be ready to go
but you know it is what it is you know
then i had to do like a i had to do like
a premium version which is like on the
audio place that i do my podcast they
they don't want they want a version with
no ads so i have to take the ads out so
it's like a little bit of editing i got
to do right now for the next like 20
minutes but i enjoy doing this they're
not always going to be live i have some
guests lined up but i just got a lot of
stuff going on you know so i i do i just
have a lot of stuff going on but
next week
you know next week i am going to be gone
i'm going on a destination wedding when
my buddy's getting married and i won't
tell you who it is until after but we're
going to a destination wedding rachel
and i and you know so we're leaving on
wednesday and we come back on sundays
and once again i'm probably gonna have
to do a live podcast version again and
i'll just probably be talking about the
wedding and
my feelings on destination weddings and
so you will do that you know and then
you know like i say i am on twitch
every single day i probably won't be all
next week because i'm gonna be doing uh
you know the wedding
but
you know thanks for listening to
riffing with griffin
you know thanks for you know all your
support i really appreciate
a lot of people came up to me in dallas
and they were like yo man you know you
help you help me get through the
pandemic with your podcast i love
hearing that kind of stuff there was
this other kid too that
man he was like he got a mo he works at
the club and he came to me and he was
like so nervous and he was like hey man
you know i just really want to thank you
for what you do you you inspired me and
he just he was getting emotional and i
didn't even know what to say you know
what i mean you don't know how you
affect people i mean unfortunately like
sometimes you know you fixate on the
trolls out there because they just suck
up all the energy in the room but i do
recognize all the people out there that
are just genuinely touched by the
podcast world and like you know
and how you feel like you know me
because the things i say here and you
just you let you want to just come up
and be like hell man i really appreciate
what you do i'm just letting you know i
appreciate you too and
thanks for being here once again so
ladies and gentlemen this has been
rhythm with griffin
[Music]
all right guys i will see you next week
this has been episode 154 riffing with
griffin and we'll